welcome to this free
webinar on genomic data analysis
this webinar is part of a special six
months
program developed in collaboration with
noguchi memorial institute for medical
research in ghana
omix logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between
pine biotech and innovative big data
welcome to this free
webinar on
i apologize for the interruption uh let
me start by sharing my screen again
so as i was talking to you about the
omics logic programs
they are part of a result of close
collaboration between prime biotech
and numerous academic institutions
around the world who have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly tested around the
world and are known to lead
to excellent outcomes for students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research
guided by mentors and pure example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
our goal is to prepare biologists and
clinicians for the influx of data
associated methodologies and data-driven
research projects
as they are prominent with the emergence
of computers for the tech industry
more and more biologists and clinicians
are now expected to understand and
handle their own data
to publish and succeed in basic and
translational research
in fact biology itself is rapidly
acquiring the character of
data science so this is what we hope
to achieve through these omics logic
programs
so the first of this six months program
was the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases focused on the use of
bioinformatics
and big data for infectious disease
research
diagnostics as well as drug and vaccine
development
this program is going to be ending on
march
10th one of the major focuses of this
program was to support
ongoing research projects which are
spearheaded by dr
anita gansha and dr bright addo's group
at nogoji and her collaborators who have
a long history of research in ghana
and other countries in sub-saharan
africa
to track monitor diagnose and study the
spread of drug resistant malaria
as well as identify novel approaches for
vaccine design
as well as the interaction between
malaria host
vector and pathogen to help conduct such
research
the upcoming omics logic genomic data
analysis
program is the second phase of the six
month long program
in this period of training participants
would get
an in-depth overview of concepts and
analytical tools
used to study genomic variations in
infectious diseases each week
participants
will meet online to discuss various
aspects of
ngs data processing genomic data
analysis
and interpretation the program starts on
march 12th and today we are going to be
talking about this program at length
in the genomics program one of the major
focus will be on the application of
bioinformatics to malaysia related
research
where we will be looking at the efficacy
of vaccines and drugs
associated with resistance and the
complexity of host pathogen
vector interaction for this purpose our
team has
already prepared a number of research
data repositories
and databases that will help the
participants identify
high impact data sets for analysis you
can see
some of them published in our recent
blogs
so dr mohit if you can kindly share the
blog with everyone in the chat
we will also discuss various
applications of
genomics to the study of sars cov2 where
selective pressure
on various proteins will lead to the
emergence
of new variants such changes are already
being seen
as a result of increased immunity
vaccination and
other host pathogen dynamics
in this upcoming omics logic program you
will have the opportunity
to interact and collaborate with our
international team of
mentors let me introduce you to them
we have dr harpreet carr who is a
certified omix logic trainer
and expert by information she will guide
the hands-on sessions and
assist participants with research
projects and analysis
during the program her area of
specialization is in genomics
and machine learning dr mohit masumdar
is our omics logic project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis he has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with industry
and academia elia brodsky is the ceo
and co-founder of buying biotech in his
current role
he has extensive experience working
together with
industry and academic partners who are
applying multi-omics
integration and bioinformatics to a
variety of biotechnology
and clinical applications i will now
invite elya to speak
more about genomic data analysis over to
you elia thank you
thank you very much pepsi and welcome
everyone to this webinar
great to see you as we get started i'll
talk a little bit about
the genomic data and what kinds of
research we're planning to do in this
program
but i also wanted to get to know a
little bit more
uh some of the participants today so if
you
can please share maybe which country
you're coming from to this webinar and
also if you can share the name of your
university
so that we have a list of
contacts that are here today let me just
check on the chat
all right great so we have somebody from
italy from
india university of delhi the
philippines
pakistan iran
india all right university of karachi
chile india all right
uh paraguay um university of management
technology
cairo university lucknow india china
all right canada egypt
[Music]
nigeria all right excellent so
a lot of people tanzania tanzania
kenya all right excellent so welcome
everyone
okay welcome everyone to this webinar i
hope that you
enjoyed today's presentation and that
you will be able to join us for the
extensive training program that we will
have starting in march
so in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data
has led to an increasing understanding
of how cells
function at the molecular level and has
allowed us to understand
some of the major causes of deadly
diseases
and with the current rise in viral
outbreaks persistent bacterial
and parasitic diseases and their
persisting deadliness
there's a major focus on developing
tools
data repositories and analysis methods
for a better understanding
of the reasons why these diseases emerge
how we can treat them and how can they
be potentially prevented with
measures like vaccines and so as a
result there has been
a major effort to collect data sets
that can characterize describe and help
us track the emergence
and the spread of these diseases so in
fact
you can see that this information is
becoming
not only collected but widely accessible
and so there are millions of sequences
and hundreds of thousands of full
genomes that are available
on repositories that are hosted by the
national center for biotechnology
information ncbi
and many other data sets databases sorry
like joint genome
institutes integrated microbial genome
databases
and these databases are growing in size
at an exponential
speed and we recently saw
that some of these are becoming more and
more
visible even to the public as we see
how the call to apply bioinformatics
tool
tools to the analysis of such data are
coming out
for example in a recent review article
in nature there has been a call
to train more people to be able to
utilize genomic data
to help track and spread the disease
as you know code 19 caused by source
code 2.
so these kinds of data sets because
they're so widely available
you can see that that it's easy to find
and download this kind of data it's easy
to
kind of develop a way to
track the newly published data sets but
there's more to the story in fact in the
same article
on nature that was published i think a
couple of days ago
it's been reported that even though we
have many
a lot of information about confirmed
cases coming out
the number of sequences varies
drastically by country
and the quality of that sequences
sequencing
is even further kind of a subject to
investigation
so whenever we have this explosion of
data
and public awareness of the type of
information that this data can produce
we also need to understand how this data
can be properly analyzed
and what kind of information can we get
out of this type of
data so bioinformatics methods that
find individual mutations like multiple
sequence alignments
can be combined with evolutionary models
which we need to understand
and track changes in the genomic
sequences that we can link to a
process and these models
fit to thousands of genomes to reveal
the dynamic tree of the pandemic which
shows
that the virus for example in in the
case of covet 19
continues to change with novel distinct
clades
separating from a common origin over the
course of the past year and so now we
know that there are approximately
12 distinct clades and their number has
grown
as you can see there have been three
clades identified
just since november 2020. the clay
proportions are likely to be unreliable
as i mentioned because of the different
levels of sequencing and the quality of
sequencing done in different countries
but
nevertheless this information has become
prominent
and central because all of us are used
to seeing this kind of information even
in the media
so as we think about the dynamic
character of viral infections and
infectious diseases
in general we might ask the question why
or what are the processes and kind of
the reasons
for such variation and dynamics
over time so what has recently been
reported
is that we now understand how
pathogenesis mechanisms of interaction
between the viral
and the or the pathogen and the host the
spread
of resistance and even immune responses
can all play
major roles in how we observe the
genomic sequence changes
in these kinds of data sets so here you
can see
how different reports from a kind of a
time course of infection and different
types of
analyses from convalescent plasma have
led to our understanding
how these mutations evolve and how do
they appear in the genomic sequences
and in fact we now know that the
individual viral genomes that we are
typically thinking of
a virus are actually whole communities
or swarms
of viruses that could be referred to as
quasi species and so today this is
becoming an
important part of diagnostic assays so
here you can see a publication
that shows the representation of the
hypothetical impact of comorbidity
on source cove to quasi species
generation and testing
where wild type source cove ii or the
most common form
is a reference for development of a
diagnostic
real-time pcr assay
or so here you can see how
this type of information could lead to a
much better understanding of
comorbidities inflammation and
increased rates in mutations that occur
in specific populations so as we develop
novel techniques and a deeper
understanding of what genomic data can
produce
we also need to evaluate the methods of
analysis that have developed
tremendously
over the past 20 to 30 years
and today we can even look beyond
individual mutations for example a
recent another recent article it
talks about multi-nucleotide deletions
where whole regions
are being deleted from these genomes and
how those
impact specific clades in the
phylogenetic tree
and even phenotype like the ability to
cause persistent infection and more
severe
infection so as a result what we have
done
is we have tried to introduce a number
of such important tools for genomic data
analysis
into a user-friendly t-bioinfo platform
that allows anyone biologists clinicians
as well as bioinformaticians that have
to deal with
hundreds or even thousands of samples at
a time to analyze this type of data
efficiently
on these on our platform we
provide specially designed sections to
deal with
infectious disease and other type of
data
so in the context of this genomics
program what we want
to do is go through all the different
types of analysis methods that are
available so that we can try to apply
them
to specific types of infectious
outbreaks
that are relevant for this cohort so
we'll talk again
about sequence alignment and mapping how
to detect
variants based on multiple sequence
alignment or
look for variants and their proportions
in next generation sequencing fast q
files
we'll also talk about analysis that
allows us to look at frequency of
mutations
as well as call variants with specific
level of confidence
and use that to find differential
mutations or mutations that can
differentiate between
different groups of samples in our data
we'll also talk about the process
of annotating those mutations and
understanding the impact of the
mutations on the
amino acid or the protein sequences
we'll look at a number of different
types of pipelines that could be built
using standardly used tools with some
modification
and we'll look for also advanced
analyses like copy number variation
we'll also see how genomic data matched
with
numeric data about phenotypes can help
us detect specific variants that are
responsible and combinations of variants
in fact that are responsible for
phenotypes such as resistance
to specific drugs or vaccines we'll also
go beyond the scenes
and go into how we can create reports
using r and python loading the final
sequence alignment
and producing detailed reports on
specific positions
and also on how these positions could be
used to understand the variation
in the data and how to select the
specific types of
mutations that are most commonly
reported and
used for example the variance of concern
in the case of source code 2. and so the
two major
directions for this upcoming genomics
program
is to talk about malaria and covet 19
or stars cove 2. so for malaria we'll
speak about
different aspects of the importance of
understanding of the overall infection
cycle
and how that infection cycle can
can help us put a context on the genomic
data
with different tools like sequence
alignment as well as
visualization and working with 3d
structures of proteins
so in this program you will see how we
will cover
a number of specific types of analyses
starting from the very basics going on
into user-friendly analysis tools and
project examples
and then incorporate some of the
training in coding
in python and r so that most of you that
join this program are enabled and are
experienced enough to be able to design
and develop
your own genomics research projects
related to infectious diseases
so this is a program that we've done
before on
different types of diseases like cancer
and others
but here we will focus specific on the
application
specifically on application of genomics
to infectious diseases
now some of you joining today might not
have a lot of background genomics so we
will provide you with information
starting from the very basics so we'll
talk about
the basic terminology what are the
building blocks of dna
and various types of dna variation like
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
what is frequency of variance how do we
differentiate between single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips
and copy number variation you'll become
knowledgeable
how to use these terms appropriately to
describe
different types of variants and master
several examples
of their importance in various
conditions
we'll also discuss the process of dna
sequencing and the different types of
dna sequences that you might find online
and we'll see how the analysis of whole
genome and exome sequencing
can be used to find variance and study
association between genotype and
phenotype
we'll also introduce you to self-guided
exampler projects that will talk about
different types of
infections that are important and
relevant to
genomic data for example we'll talk
about
ebola virus the outbreak in 2014 2016
how to find specific genomic
genomes in cell lines that
are used for biologics we'll talk about
the origins and pathogenesis of the
novel coronavirus
and we'll see how to use genome-wide
association studies
to understand tuberculosis infection and
drug resistance so when we talk about
ebola
it's a great example because it was one
of the first
outbreaks that we saw almost real time
generation
and sharing of large-scale genomic data
in this project you will see how the
tracking
of the infection can be applied to
genomic data that is available on ncbi
virus
and you will be able to create
phylogenetic trees
to study genomic association with
geolocation
as well as time you'll also see how
mapping of those mutations between
nucleotide and amino acid sequence
reveals important variation in groups of
samples that are available
on these public repositories but we'll
also go beyond that and we'll talk about
this host variation where you can see
local haplotype reconstruction using
methods
that analyze closely related sequences
in raw reads of fastq files as a result
you will be able to use this information
to track
ebola virus transmission and see the
impact of specific variants
on vaccine design in another project on
the origin
and pathogenesis of the novel
coronavirus we will also talk about
how we can detect where was the first
emergence
of this important pathogen and how we
can use phylogenetic analysis
to track the development of this
pandemic and try to see
how closely related this novel pathogen
is to
some of the previously studied and well
characterized coronaviruses
again we'll use multiple sequence
alignment where we compare
different sequences from sars bats
tangolin
and other types of coronaviruses to
understand the
impact of specific genomic variations on
protein structure and interaction but
we'll also talk about the emergence
of treatment approaches to
this important pathogen and we'll see
how transcriptomic data
can also be used to find association
between treatment response
and specific types of pathways that are
responsible for efficacy
and inflammation so ultimately you will
find
that the application of genomic data
will be described for viral genomics and
evolution
for immune response and biomarkers and
microbiome and infection and so we will
lead
from genomic data characterization into
multi-omics integration
ultimately linking the genomic variants
with pathway analysis in another example
for tuberculosis
we'll talk about genome-wide association
studies where
our goal is to find the association
between
specific individual variants and
the different types of resistance to
either
a single type of treatment or multi-drug
resistance where
multiple types of treatments are being
used so in that case you will learn
how to use genome wide association
studies
and use different approaches for gys
analysis
to ideally understand the specific
genes and their mutations in the context
of many many different samples that we
will analyze together
and so we will also look at how to
produce a report
and characterize the resistance
emergence
throughout different regions around the
world
now as i mentioned genomic data
characterization
has improved to the level where we can
go beyond
individual mutations and start looking
at other types of outbreaks
where defective genomes are responsible
for spread
and disease process so here we will
use the enterovirus d68
which was reported across the different
parts of the globe
especially in the us and europe and
we will see an outbreak of this virus in
2012
2014 and 2016 where there was
a different pathogenicity between
different populations
so here we will use a phylogenetic tree
reconstruction algorithm
to find out whether evd68 strains from
different
outbreaks at different time points are
similar
or different based on the phylogenetic
analysis
of patient data here we will use the
variation
and the strains to identify clades
related to
specific dates of outbreaks and
we will finally look at how specific
variants can characterize these
individual strains
that are either on the nucleotide or the
amino acid level
so to talk about how you can gain access
to a lot of these program resources
i will pass this back on to beepsec and
she will introduce you to
the process of registration
thank you so much elia so i will
continue by
sharing my screen right here
so as i'm going to be starting talking a
little bit about the program resources
i want to get started by launching a
poll here
on the screen so this is just a poll to
know more about who you
are as you see that in the chat we have
uh
participants who are coming from
different
countries around the world they have
different interests
so please let us know the first question
here as you see is which country you are
from
so there are several options if you're
from any other country
then you can mention the other countries
that you're from
in the chat box the second question is
what is your level of
education then the third is how familiar
are you with genomics as we are talking
primarily about genomics
so we are going to be asking you the
question but
in case you're also interested in any
other topic
like anirudh mentioned more about ngos
data analysis focused on transcriptomics
or microbiome data analysis so if you're
interested in any of these topics you
can also let us know in the chat box
and if you share your email id with us
so we will be reaching out to you and
the last question
i wanted to add here was how did you
learn
about the genomics webinar so where did
you come to know about this webinar that
you're attending today did you receive
an email from us did you see
the webinar on facebook linkedin
instagram or was it recommended to you
by any friend or
peer or faculty please uh put them down
in the poll so we'll keep the poll on
for just another minute
while i answer a question from polo me
in the chat box
so polo me says i'm an undergraduate
biotechnology student can i do any of
the courses you are providing
yes follow me you can do any of the
courses we are providing
and this is because of the program
resources that i'm going to be sharing
so you will notice that when we are
talking about the resources it starts
with
courses which begin at a very
primary and introductory level so
we give you access to these resources
from where you can start
learning and supplement that learning
along with
online sessions like this webinar that
we are having today
so as part of the omics logic genomics
program
we will be having online sessions i will
be quickly taking everybody through that
schedule shortly and also show you
how you will be learning from each of
these resources so every week
we'll give you some assignments give you
some tasks
that you have to complete and this you
can do along with any of the other
studies that you're doing
if you're a college student or if you
have uh if you're pursuing your phd you
can do this
so if you are looking forward to join a
program like this
we recommend a minimum of six to eight
hours per week if you
want to make the best out of the program
and even if you are someone who is very
busy
may not be able to attend all of the
online sessions
we also record each of the session
videos and send it to our participants
so
the session recordings will also be
available for all of the sessions that
we will be doing
okay so i'm reading some of the
questions that
are here so i will also be introducing
everybody to the other programs
that are available as part of the omics
logic programs that we do and we have
several of those but today as we are
focused on genomics
and infectious diseases so we are going
to be talking a little bit about this
and moving into the other programs and
everybody who is sharing please continue
to post
your uh email ids or any of the
feedback that you have in the chat box
today's session tanvi is free of course
our training program is not free of cost
so i will be talking about
the costs right at the end so i think uh
we have received the poll
uh so uh elia doctor can you confirm
because i cannot see if the poll
is being done so i can end the poll now
yes i think you can end the poll i see
there's been
voted
okay thank you so much india so i will
be ending the poll now thank you all for
sharing
so omix logic program is built to
provide students of all backgrounds
with a clear perspective on big data
analytics machine learning
and artificial intelligence in
application to omics data
for research clinical and industry
applications
our omics logic step-by-step process
is enabled by access to complex tools
via a simple and intuitive interface
at the same time exposing participants
to analysis logic
in the context of real data sets and
extrapolation of this logic
to a variety of projects and data sets
with
assistance from mentors and technical
support as we have seen india tell us so
far
the program licenses include access to
tutorials and project
examples big data analysis tools
coding training and mentor support
so this is all included in all of the
program licenses
and i'm going to be talking in depth
about this in
short while so let us start by signing
up to
eduti bioinfo so if you are not already
a member of the platform please start by
signing up to eduti buyer info
and dr moyet if you can kindly share the
link in the chat box
the edutiba info portal
has introductory courses which leads to
multiple
other courses and projects that can
serve as a springboard into the world of
bioinformatics
and here learning about genomic data
analysis
and we also have several projects that
you see
some of which elia has also discussed
for the duration of the program we will
also be using the t
bio info platform to process big data
sets
this platform is built for multi-omics
integration and
analysis of structured data with
advanced methods like machine learning
and mathematical modeling
for downstream analysis and
visualization of process
data there are many packages in popular
coding languages
like r and python which you can learn on
the code
omics logic playground additional coding
exercises
will also be used to practice sequence
alignment
evolutionary studies and interpretation
of found
variants
so let us now go together to see how to
register
for this program so for this i will be
sharing my screen and on my screen you
have the registration page link
thank you all for sharing the email id
right now so this is the registration
link
so now let's quickly take a look at what
we can see in this page so we have the
start date which is 12th of march
so we are going to be starting very soon
in less than 10 days
the program time is the same time that
we started today which is 9
am cst or 9 am central standard time
and if you are from any other country
outside of the us
please convert it to your local time in
india time
it will be 8 30 pm ist in gmt it will be
3 pm gmt
and once you go down here we have also
prepared a video for the session that
you can see so you can learn more about
what we are going to be talking about
here is a program overview and once you
scroll down
you find the schedule for the session
so here is the entire schedule for the
session so you can actually go through
the different topics that we will be
dealing with
in each of these sessions and we will
have bi-weekly sessions here
and let me take you through the
registration process so once you're in
this page if you're looking forward to
get started
you have to click on get started and you
will notice that
we offer three licensing options so this
is what i was referring to
uh when i meant that we offer licensing
for this program
so these licenses cover the resources
that we have just spoken about
earlier so we have a beginner's license
so what does the beginner license
constitute of the beginner license
constitutes of
all the resources we mentioned which is
the asynchronous course materials the
live sessions the hands-on assignments
group sessions as well as projects
and how is it different from the
intermediate and advanced
so the intermediate comes with an extra
benefit where you can request
time for one of the mentors to mentor
you on a one-on-one session so if you
have
any questions or if you feel like that
you want to take the program at a pace
as well as
learn from one-on-one sessions and not
just the group sessions you can request
for this and for that you can take the
intermediate license
while the advanced license is a research
license
which means that if you are looking
forward to doing research using genomics
data
or similar kind of data then what we
recommend
is having the advanced license so what
does the advanced license give you it
gives you an
additional 30 days so we already see
that
the program is going to be ending on
15th april
so you for you if you are taking the
advanced license it's going to be giving
you additional 30 days so which means
that
your program access will end on the 15th
of may and you can actually do
a research project in that extra period
of time
along with our mentor team and also work
together with the research fellows
we have and thank you so much bhagat
singh for sharing
so these are the different options we
have for payment
and we will be sharing any other details
that you require and we also understand
that there are some students who might
need help in joining the session
so we also offer scholarship so i will
also paste the scholarship
link right in the chat box and the goal
of the scholarship
is to offer students who are bright and
who might need help in
attending a training program like this
and there are some requirements that a
student would need to follow
to fill up and to get access to the
program
as part of the scholarship so if you
noticed
on this page you have a form now what
you need to do is if you're applying for
the scholarship please make sure that
you're
filling up all of these fields so if you
just write
nil your scholarship will not be granted
so we need to
especially meet with you and your
reference
so this is very important the goal is to
make sure
that you are going to be following
through a program like this
that the faith that we are providing you
the scholarship you are going to be
doing the tasks that are assigned to you
so basically if you
are receiving a scholarship you will be
assigned few tasks which
means that you have to give us constant
updates of your progress
throughout the training you have to send
us reviews
of the courses that you do so you have
to be very involved
in this entire training so once you're
filling out the form
please make sure you do this as soon as
possible because we will have to set up
meetings with you
and one of your references who can be
from the institute
or the university that you come from so
we also present to them this opportunity
we talk with you
and then based on that discussion you
are offered the scholarship
so if you want to take scholarship for
this program please mention here
as well which program you're applying
for for
and you can anybody can apply for this
scholarship but it will only be given
once we have that discussion with you
so uh bhagat can you see the chat box
i've shared the scholarship link again
and i will also share the link for the
genomics
program right here on the chat box
here again and while i'm talking about
this i also wanted to invite everybody
to join our social media groups
so in the social media groups you will
see that we have
a lot of participants who are coming
from different parts of the world
and they are just like you scholars
students researchers as well as
faculties and administrators from
different parts of the world so it's a
great place
for you to go ahead and get started
knowing
from different people and collaborating
with us so we believe in collaboration
and we do hope that we are able to
collaborate with you and we also have a
facebook page
so i'm also sharing the link here
of the facebook page
and let me paste it in the chat box so
these are the few pages that we have for
different uh sections and whoever
whichever social media you are
comfortable
using and we also have
other programs that are coming up so as
anirudh
was requesting we do have this
transcriptomics program that we started
on second month so we have had
only one session so far the next session
is going to be on
friday which is march 5th so anirudh if
you are interested in learning more
about
ngs data analysis and not only under
anybody else
who is interested in learning more about
uh this kind of data analysis you can go
ahead and check out this link the
registration process
is the same as well as the scholarship
link remains the same just when you are
applying for the scholarship please
mention the program that you are
interested in
as we have several different programs
that we are running
at the moment so i do hope that you all
are able to take
part in programs like this and take
this opportunity and i'll quickly stop
sharing and
find the link to the other programs for
everybody here
so okay this is the link to the other
programs that we
are having as part of
the several omics logic programs that we
are doing this
spring summer so let me quickly again
share my screen
and share this link so via this link
what you can do
is see the different programs that we
have
so we have a research fellowship program
uh shubham we do not offer any phd
programs
but we do have a program on research
fellowship
and i will quickly explain what it is
the goal of this program
is to help you
design or develop your own novel
research project
so this is a program completely focused
on research projects it's offered for
either three months or
six months and we work with students we
work with even high school students who
are doing
really well under this program where
they are getting started on their
research journey way earlier and that is
possible using the
resources that we offer like the big
data analysis server platform that you
saw
which has multi-omics integration so you
can understand the different
applications and how easy it is because
it's there in the cloud and a student
just needs to log into the platform
in the browser and use the platform
so this is the bioinformatics research
fellowship program
and the next program that we have is
this program that we are seeing today
which is the
omits logic genomic program so whenever
you are applying for any of these
programs
please make sure that you're selecting
the program you're interested in and
this is the omex logic training program
that we are running currently in india
but
we also accept any kind of international
participation
and whoever is joining us now
and we also have another program coming
up focused
on precision oncology
so this program is going to be starting
on march
15th and this is also
another program where we are going to be
focusing
more on cancer biology tumor development
etc and if you are someone who is
working with cancer
or you are interested in going towards a
research area like this that you can
also apply for this program and i'll
just show you
how to apply for this so you notice that
there is a form at the end of the page
and you can actually choose from this
different programs that you would want
to apply for so once you select
a program you will receive an email
regarding
the program so please make sure that
you're selecting the program of your
choice
and if you want to apply for multiple
programs then please fill up the form
twice
and make sure you're selecting the
options uh different options at this
different time period
and thank you so much if you all have
any questions so research fellowship
right
so okay so manisha what do you want to
know more about the research fellowship
if you can let me know then maybe i can
clarify it for you
while for mega genomics yes we just
concluded a metagenomic program so we
had this metagenomic program
uh that we started in february so it's
going to be expiring very soon
so for all the programs so all the
programs have different costs
so you would have to go ahead and
subscribe and see what all these
programs
cost for so maybe you can reach out to
me
i obama and i can share with you if you
want to join all of these programs and
please note that
some of the sessions may be clashing so
we would recommend you to start with one
and then progress to others because
we'll keep on repeating
uh these kinds of programs even in the
coming summer months
so this is my email id thank you uh dr
mohit
marketing at pine dot bio is my email id
for reaching out to me
yeah thank you and for everyone reaching
out for us to
for these different programs that we are
offering so this is the website where
you can actually apply for these
programs and then you will get
emails about the entire process that how
we are going to conduct the sessions
when the program is going to start
and all the other details like the free
sessions that we are doing associated
with this
these programs and also for research
fellowship
we are doing this with participants who
have
uh who have learned from one of the
omics logic programs
and now they want to work on their
project and finalize the project and
trans uh
and then uh move to a way
where they can present the project and
show it to their peers and also like may
be published
so that's the entire structure of the
research fellowship program
however i mean if you're interested
please go to this link and
fill up the form and we'll be emailing
you as well
thank you yeah thank you so much dr
mohit and um i would just want to answer
some of the questions which i see right
now so when exactly is the research
fellowship starting
so the research fellowship does not have
a commencement date
our research fellows work throughout the
year on different research projects what
we aim to do is help you
develop your own research project so you
can start joining
today and we you will get started with
your three month or six months research
journey
so the research fellowship again to
answer swati's question
be will it be containing details on data
science applications with healthcare
so each of the research fellowship
program
is focused on training you in an area
you are interested in and developing a
project so mainly if you are interested
in working on a project
we start with the training and help you
go through this and elia will also be
explaining the process shortly
and to answer avoca's question
is the application for research
fellowship free or does scholarship
cover it as well
so the application again for the
research fellowship program is not free
but definitely you can again go ahead
and apply for scholarship
the criterion of selection for
scholarship as i
mentioned is based on the conversation
that we will have with you
on a one-on-one meeting with your mentor
so please make sure that the details
that you're entering is
correct and it would also require you to
perform certain tasks as i mentioned
which we will mention to you during the
meeting that we have
so now i would like to pass back this
session to elia to discuss some of the
projects over to you elia
okay thank you people again um thank you
everyone for
the informative questions um i
briefly wanted to mention that many of
the programs that you
are seeing here are designed to help you
conduct independent research and to do
research using bioinformatics it's
important to
find a data set to learn about the
application of
different methods and it's also a
collaborative
process so you really need to work with
others on different components of your
project project for example if you come
from
a bioinformatics background already
you might want to find a collaborator
that is more biology burst
if you are coming from a biology
background maybe you will find it
challenging to conduct certain types of
research
with coding and computational tools
and also describing your methods so the
program that we have
and we typically have between 10 and 20
fellows at a time we try to facilitate
this process
allowing you to gain access to all of
the different training sessions that we
have
know about the different types of
analysis
using different tutorials and project
examples
and we typically see a slow transition
between
learning to then designing your research
question
and finding the data set that you will
study that question using
and then eventually working with you to
help you
polish up the presentation and
potentially even write a paper
so i pasted a link here to a number of
uh recent projects that have been
completed by different participants
and i want to just show you this is just
a few examples really it's not
a comprehensive list but to get you an
idea
one of the major kind of stepping stones
for a lot of people once they design a
project
is to be able to get some feedback on
what it is like
what did people think about it what do
other people who are either experts in
this field
or experts in bioinformatics what can
they say about the project and so
typically that has been done
in the context of poster presentations
where students can present their posters
and get some feedback answer questions
etc so
we essentially provide an online version
of that
by conducting regular meetings where
both
experts and other peers can provide
feedback to a project presentation
and also eventually when the project is
done
and sometimes that project is ready for
a publication we
guide you on how to submit that
publication and help you
make sure that the draft is good
and then also we have a number of
collaborators at the tower
bioinformatics research center
and in other places that we asked to
evaluate
the project from an expert perspective
and so here are some examples of posters
that
range from alzheimer's disease to
cancer to infectious diseases and others
some people take very cutting edge
projects like the effect of
radiation on the microbiome in space and
other people apply to very immediate
types of challenges
you can see here for example
identification and imaging of potential
vaccine targets versus our scope 2
spikes a really
diverse range of projects that are
either done
independently like here you see a
project by urja
and sometimes in groups here you can see
a collaboration between a number of
different people that work together
so oftentimes i think as a result of
such collaborations you get to
understand a project from multiple
perspectives
and it also in the context of a short
time frame
can prepare you for a longer plan to
conduct a project
in a more thorough way so for example
our
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program with the university of ghana
is scheduled for six months and the
reason for that is because just now
after
maybe a month and a half of training the
participants are starting to
really work on their project
presentations
and that's one of the things that i
actually wanted to mention that
we have an upcoming session where you
can see
some of those presentations where
students
and faculty and researchers that have
completed some
training program will be sharing their
projects proposals project proposals
um so um we will have this
available on march 10th it will be a
session where we will have some of our
research fellows
present some of the people that have
worked
under a scholarship that have summarized
kind of what they have learned
and we will have some of the
participants of the first phase of the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
where you will find proposals on malaria
and on source cove too so uh
beeps i don't know if you can share the
link
for this session or if you have
submitted your email address we will be
emailing you
that information uh maybe by the end of
this week
so we welcome those of you especially
those of you that are interested in
applying bioinformatics to different
research problems to reach out to us
maybe some of you would like to speak
about
your project and about your
um you know what to do with your project
essentially
so please do reach out to us uh dr muhit
mazumdar here
is curating a lot of data sets and
helping
groups of students kind of develop their
project proposals
so you can definitely reach out to us
marketing at pine.bio or mohit
at pine dot bio to schedule a
discussion about your project um and
we also want to mention that in many
cases
the way this works best is for faculty
that do not have
sufficient time to dedicate to a project
but would like
help from their students guiding
being guided by some expert to develop
an analysis
so another option is really to join a
program
together with your students maybe two or
three students that can do
the analysis and you can kind of provide
the oversight and guidance
on selecting the topic and making sure
that the analysis is good
so if you have any questions about those
please do reach out to us
specifically and i'll pass it on back to
you
beep said to kind of answer some of the
questions that are being asked
thank you so much elia and thank you
manassa for
sharing the sharing with us this
feedback
i hope that everybody is now able to see
my screen
so at this point i would like to ask if
you have
any other questions please feel free to
reach out to us
so we have shared three email ids in the
chat box one is mohit
fine dot bio to reach out to dr mohit
regarding any kind of questions that you
may have regarding projects
collaborations
if you want to reach out to us regarding
the research fellowship the programs or
any other opportunities
please feel free to reach out to me
marketing at pine.bio
even regarding any kind of access that
you would want
to different websites that we have or
the different portals that we offer
and we also have a team in africa based
out of nigeria
so you can reach out to our africa team
if you are based on in nigeria
africa or ghana or any of these
countries
africa pine dot bio is the email id
so if you do not have any other
questions
thank you all for joining today's
session
so uh abu kari uh you can reach out to
adidas is a community manager in
africa so regarding any kind of
uh problems with get credit card or any
other payment issues
for participants in africa nigeria
please reach out to aditayo so africa
pilot bio is
email id you can also send that email to
me and i will be able to
help you connect with adidas as well
so thank you adida for sharing this so
do we have any other questions and thank
you polo me for sharing the
feedback
thank you burhan thank you son
okay yeah so delago yes we do have
professionals
as well who apply for this program which
means that professionals who belong to
any of these domains
in biotechnology bioinformatics
and they too would want to learn more
about bioinformatics application
especially industry professionals so yes
we do also
train them so if you have any specific
uh requests regarding that please reach
out to me
i will be able to help you so again i
would like to invite everybody to
connect with us
so here you would be able to see the
different
people who are there in the groups
interact with them we do hope that
you're able to interact with us and ask
us questions as
well we are also active on instagram
so please go ahead and follow us on
these links
on instagram you can find us at
bioinformatics spine
and we are also there on youtube so our
youtube channel name is fine biotech as
you saw that dr mother shared earlier we
had streamed this session live
on youtube so it will be available there
for
review if you want to go go ahead and
review this later
so thank you all i would want to end
today's session
i look forward to seeing you all in the
upcoming omics logic genomic program or
any of the other programs that we are
offering have a wonderful day everyone
and please feel free to email us
regarding any
questions that you may have thank you
and have a good